a couple of interesting things that we
humans do
uh one is object manipulation and
movement
and of course movement was something
that was done
that was another big invention being
able to move around the environment
um and the other one is
this sensory mechanism how we sense the
environment one of the coolest high
definition ones is vision
uh how big are those inventions in the
history
of uh life on earth
vision movement uh i mean again
extremely important going back to the
origin of animals the cambrian explosion
where suddenly you're seeing eyes in the
fossil record and you can it's not
necessarily again lots of people
historically have said what use is half
an eye and and
you know you can go in a series of steps
uh from a a light sensitive spot on a
flat piece of tissue to an eyeball with
a lens and so on um if you assume no
more than than i don't remember this
this was a specific model that i have in
mind but it was you know
one percent change or half a percent
change for each generation how long
would it take to evolve and i as we know
it and the answer is half a million
years
um it doesn't have to take long that's
not how evolution works that's not a
that's not an answer to the question it
just shows you can reconstruct the steps
and you can work out roughly how it can
work so it's not that big a deal to
evolve an eye
but once you have one then there's
nowhere to hide and uh again we're back
to predator prey relationships we're
back to all the benefits that being able
to see brings you and if you think you
know philosophically what bats are doing
with eco-location and so on
i have no idea but i suspect that they
form an image of the world in pretty
much the same way that we do it's just a
matter of mental reconstruction so i
suppose the other thing about sight
there are single celled
organisms that have got
a lens
and a a retina and a and a cornea and so
on basically they've got a camera type
eye in a single cell they don't have a
brain
what they understand about their world
is impossible to say but but they're
capable of coming up with with the same
structures to do so so i suppose then
is that once you've got things like eyes
then you have a big driving pressure on
the central nervous system to figure out
what it all means
and we come around to your other point
about manipulation sensory input and so
on about you now now you
you you have a huge requirement to
understand what your environment is and
what it means and how it reacts and how
you should run away and where you should
stay put
actually on that point let me i don't
know if you know the work of donald
hoffman
who talks about
who uses the argument
um
the mechanism of evolution
to say that
there's not necessarily a
strong evolutionary
value
to seeing the world as it is
so objective reality that our perception
actually
is very different from what's
objectively real
we're living inside an illusion and
we're basically the entire
uh the entire
set of species on earth i think i i
guess are competing in a space that's an
illusion that's distinct from this far
away from physical reality as it is as
defined by physics i'm not sure it's an
illusion so much as a bubble i mean we
have a sensory input which is a fraction
of what we could have a sensory input on
um and we interpret it in terms of
what's useful for us to know to stay
alive so yes it's an illusion in that
sense but
the tree is physically there and if you
walk into that tree you you know that
there is it's not purely a delusion
there's some physical reality to it so
it's a it's a uh
sensory slice into reality as it is but
because it's just a slice you're missing
a big picture but he says that that
slice doesn't necessarily need to be a
slice
it could be a complete fabrication
that's just consistent amongst the
species which is an interesting or at
least it's a humbling
realization that our perception
is limited and our cognitive abilities
are limited
and
at least to me
it's argument from evolution i don't
know how much how how strong that is as
an argument
but
i do think that life can exist
in the mind
uh
yes in the same way that you can do a
virtual reality video game and you can
have a vibrant life inside that place
and that place is not
real in some sense but you can still
have a vibe all the same forces of
evolution all the same
competition the dynamics of uh between
humans you can have but i don't know
if um
i don't know if there's evidence for
that being the thing that happened on
earth it seems that earth i think in
either environment i wouldn't deny that
you could have exactly the world that
you talk about and it would be very
difficult to
uh you know the the idea um in in matrix
movies and so on that the whole world is
completely
a construction um and we're
fundamentally deluded it's it's it's
difficult to say that's impossible or
couldn't happen or
and certainly we construct in our minds
what the outside world is but we do it
on input and that input
i would hesitate to say it's not real
um because it's precisely how we do
understand the world we you know we have
eyes but if you keep someone in
apparently this kind of thing happens
someone kept in a dark room for five
years or something like that they never
see properly again because they've
the the the what neural wiring that
underpins how we interpret vision never
developed
you know you need when you watch a child
develop it walks right walks into a
table it bangs his head on the table and
it hurts
and
now you've got two inputs you've got one
pane from this sharp edge and number two
you probably you've touched it and
realized it's there it's a sharp edge
and you've got the visual input and you
put the three things together and think
i don't want to walk into a table again
so you're learning and and it's a
limited reality but it's a true reality
and if you don't learn that properly
then you will get eaten you will get hit
by a bus you will not survive
uh and same if you if you're in in some
kind of uh
let's say computer construction of
reality i'm not in my ground here but if
if you construct the laws that this is
what reality is inside in inside this
then you play by those laws yeah i mean
as long as the laws are consistent so
just like you said in the lab
the interesting thing about the
simulation question yes it's hard to
know if we're living inside a simulation
but
also yes it's possible to do these kinds
of experiments in the lab now
more and more to me the interesting
question is
how
realistic does a virtual reality game
need to be for us to not be able to tell
the difference
a more interesting question to me is
how
realistic
or
interesting does the virtual reality
world need to be in order for us to want
to stay there forever
or much longer than
physical reality prefer that place and
also prefer it not as we prefer
uh hard drugs but prefer it in a deep
meaningful way in the way we
we enjoy
i mean i suppose the issue with the
matrix i i imagine that it's possible to
to delude the mind sufficiently that you
genuinely in that way do think that you
are
interacting with the real world when in
fact the whole thing's a simulation
how good does the simulation need to be
to be able to do that well it it needs
to um
convince you that all your sensory input
is correct and accurate and and and
joins up and makes sense now that
sensory input is not something that
we're born with we're born with a sense
of touch we're born with eyes and some
but we don't know how to use them we
don't know what to make of them
we go around we bump into trees we cry a
lot we're in pain a lot we you know
we're
we're basically booting up the system so
that it it can make head a tail of the
sensory input that it's getting and that
sensory input's not just a one-way flux
of things it's also you have to walk
into things you have to hear things you
have to put it together now if you've
got just babies in in the matrix who are
slotted into this i don't think they
have that kind of sensory input i don't
think they would have any way to make
sense of new york
uh as a world that they're part of
the the brain is just not developed in
that way so i can't make sense of new
york in this physical reality either but
yeah i mean but you said pain and
walking into things well you can create
a pain signal and as long as it's
consistent
that certain things result in pain you
can start to construct a reality there's
some maybe maybe you disagree with this
but i think
we are born
almost with a desire to be convinced by
our reality
like a
desire to make sense of our reality oh
i'm sure we are yeah so there's an
imperative so whatever that reality is
given to us like the table hurts fire is
hot yeah i think
we want to be deluded
in the sense that we want to make a
simple like einstein
simple theory of the thing around us
yeah we want that simplicity and so um
maybe
the hunger for the simplicity is the
thing that could be used to construct a
pretty dumb simulation
that that tricks us so maybe tricking
humans doesn't require building a
universe
no i i don't i mean i this is not what i
work on so i don't know how close to it
we are
working but i i agree with you
yeah i'm not sure that it's
a morally justifiable thing to do but
it's it's
is it possible in principle
um
i think it'll be very difficult
but i don't see why in principle it
wouldn't be possible and i agree with
you that it's it's um that we try to
understand the world we try to integrate
the sensory inputs that we have and we
try to come up with a hypothesis that
explains what's going on
i think though
that we have
huge input from
the social context that we're in we
don't do it by ourselves we don't kind
of blunder around in a universe by
ourself and
understand the whole thing we're told by
the people around us uh what things are
and what they do and you know language
is coming in here and so on so
it would have to be an extremely
impressive simulation to simulate all of
that
you